right we're leaving we're streaming live
right okay i'll begin good afternoon
everyone
and welcome to this planner meeting my
name is lawrence walsh and i am the
chair
of this committee councillor aidan
williams is the vice chair
we have an attendance this afternoon
planning officers together with
officers from legal highways democratic
services
and members of council who make up this
planning committee
for everyone's information this meeting
is being live streamed and recorded
for subsequent broadcast please can i
ask you to
mute your microphone to minimize
background noise
if you wish to speak please notify me
through the chat
facility okay so item number one
is attendances and i've got apologies
from
councillor kerry and council accordingly
there are no other apologies that i'm
aware of
unless anybody wants to um
[Music]
wants to advise me otherwise um item
number two is declarations of interest
and let let me read this out
proper to everybody members to give
notes of any personal
or prejudicial interest and the nature
of that interest relating to any item on
the agenda in accord with you
with the adopted code of conduct of any
members
got any interest to declare now is the
time to do that
no that's that's good okay item number
three is questions from members of the
public
and questions have been submitted by mr
mancula of ridding court
representing a number of residents from
the timperley ward
regarding the application we'll be
discussing tonight 92 to 94
park road um in timperley
these have been rejected as they are
considered to be
an additional representation and as such
they are addressed within the additional
information report
which we've all had copies of i'm sure
um and that is item number four the
additional information you've had that
on an email this afternoon i'm certain
and we don't have minutes uh tonight to
approve but we've got action number five
applications to develop and uh
just a reminder to everybody that as
well as our
local knowledge we look to the
background papers listed at the
beginning
of a gender item 5 as a basis
for our decision making this evening so
hope everybody knows that thank you so
we'll go into the applications
and we're going to go to
page one on your main agenda and that's
the former kellogg sites albert road
and we have an introduction from mr
pearson
am i right insane that's right
councillor yes um
if you can just bear with me i'll try
and share my screen with you
and i'll take you through the through
the presentation
okay can everybody see the screen yes
thank you okay so um this is
um an outline application at the former
kellogg's site
just across the road from the town hall
you can see the site there
edged in red on that aerial photo
the outline application seeks approval
for a mix of uses that you can see on
the screen there
it's residential led but includes office
local center uses a primary school
a hotel energy center and other
ancillary elements including
public groundworks and landscaping
approval is only sought for access so
other reserve
matters such as the layout of the site
the appearance of buildings
scale of them and landscaping will all
follow in subsequent applications should
this
outline application be approved
the quantum of development you see on
the screen there the site can't
accommodate all that
development those those are maximum
since the the up to reference for a
number of those
uses so it would really depend um upon
the mix of uses coming forward whether
you would get
a full 750 dwellings or whether there
might be a smaller amount
depending upon how many of the other
uses came forward
given the scale and nature of the scheme
it's considered to represent
environmental impact assessment
development
and the environmental impact assessment
submission concludes that there'll be no
significant effects
on the environment arising from the
scheme subject to the embedded
mitigation measures and further
mitigation being secured
by appropriate planning conditions it
concludes that there is no reason to
withhold
planning permission on the basis of the
environment mental impacts of that
development of the development
and officers agree with with that
conclusion
so the scheme is accompanied by
an illustrative master plan um even
though it
approval is only sought for access so it
includes information to give us an idea
of how the site
might look so you see there an aerial
shot of the site
you can perhaps see you ain't the
existing ua 92 building
um i'll just try and make the cursor
clearer
if you can see that the existing ua 92
building in the middle of the screen
and then you've got another of them a
number of other buildings surrounding it
i mean the site sits within the wider
civic quarter area and it's consistent
this proposal is consistent with
council's vision or that wider area
as set out in the draft area action plan
that i'm sure you've
seen it's a relatively high
dense mixed use development and
it could end up looking something like
this um
there are likely to be buildings in
front of ua 92
and then the height of the buildings
would rise as you move away from
the point closest to the town hall and
the area by the cricket ground
over in a northeasterly direction to
this point here where you're close to
the existing
oakland house building which i'm i'm
indicating with the cursor here
another drawing there from the
illustrative master plan
um that just indicates where where you
how it you might have a number of
buildings arranged on the site
so there's the ua 92 building again and
then you can see a number of other
buildings set out around it that's not
to say that the site would come forward
like this that's
that's only illustrative
in terms of the vision there are a
number of uh sort of visual images
uh accompanying the application which
again give you a feel for how
the site might look um there's
uh three areas of open space within the
site the largest one you see there
close to the proposed school building
but then you can see the back of ua 92
and some of the other buildings sitting
around it
so whilst it's a fairly dense
development there are as i say a number
of attractive buildings
um it suggests that a very attractive
environment
can be can be created and there's a just
there's just another image of how
a typical street might look um we'll
come on to this later but um
the idea is to try and keep the motor
car out of the site
um so that we can deliver some streets
that are
that are you know for pedestrians and
for people to play on so there's um
there's an image depicting that on
screen there
in terms of the the use and the and the
see the word typologies on the building
it's the type of buildings that might
might come forward again i'll start with
ua 92
in the in the center of the site
suggestion is that we could have offices
in front of
ua 92 associated with it it's hoped that
as the university grows
the the business partners of the office
use that's currently in ua 92 will need
to move out to allow the university to
expand
and the idea is that we provide some
office space for for those businesses to
move into
as an energy center suggested to rear of
ua 92 here
schools over in this corner of the site
um and then we've got apartments the
tallest buildings
over here where the cursor is now and
then dropping down in height behind here
on the car parking uh multi-storey car
park
200 space car parking in that part of
the site there as you move down to the
west corner of the site the height
generally drops and you have town houses
that that might
just be three or four stories in height
and mansion blocks that perhaps
probably six stories something like that
along ground state and way there
so whilst approval is only sought for
access
as i said there are a number of other
drawings and submissions accompanying
the application and one of those
uh is is this land use parameter plan
and that indicates the the uses and
where they're likely to go on the site
so again you can see ua 92 in the
cross-hatched area there
and this darker blue or mid blue
uh zoning here would be a mix of
residential
office higher education and energy
center
and local center uses the light blues
the highway brian statham way until the
road
a lion green area there that's um that's
open space
other schools down in in this corner
here
the other parameter plan that's been
submitted relates to
building heights so if the application
were to be approved there would be a
condition
that basically says that any reserve
matters application
uh subsequent to this would need to
abide by the maximum
uh heights shown on on this plan um
and that's not to say that those
buildings would all hit that maximum
height it's just
to give an indication of what we think
the the highest point should be
so uh just to talk you through this one
you could brian statham weighs
there on the cricket ground here so a
long brown state away
the limit there would be six stories
that would be consistent with the
hotel that lancashire cricket club were
proposing
and then as i said as you move away from
that area
heights starts to increase so buildings
up to eight stories in this
story sorry in this uh peachy coloured
area um up to 12 here
in the the sort of mid purple and then
go going higher still up to 15 stories
here
and up to 20 stories at this uh
northeastern corner of the site so
what's anticipated is that you would get
scale that would increase gradually
in height from from this corner of the
site up here
and again up here that's not to say all
of the buildings would get taller
um the illustrative master plans look to
show a mix of
um heights within within within the
building
but it's sort of within sight the
density of development which is why
we're on this
point is is higher than we're used to
seeing on large housing sites you know
if you think of sites like
carrington village but the context of
course is very different
um you could perhaps see from the the
other drawings that we had up earlier
with the illustrative master plan
how the building blocks were closer
together um
to say height in some parts of the site
but then lower building through the
others
um it is worth noting this thing that
noting sorry that whilst the density is
is higher than we might have typically
seen um
it's certainly not as high as on many of
the schemes that we're seeing coming
forward along
tolbert road where you perhaps got one
or two buildings
sat on a much smaller site those sites
are generally not able to offer the
level of open space and
public realm that this scheme intends to
deliver
um it's also worth bearing in mind of
course that the site has excellent
public transport
links it's close to manchester city
centre and close to
uh other community facilities uh close
to the site
shop schools the town hall so a very
sustainable location
and this is because of that this is the
type of location where
the the mppf is encouraged encouraging
us to deliver
higher density mixed use schemes
making effective use of land but at the
same time delivering a development
which is well designed and attractive
so it's considered that the variation in
the maximum building heights across the
site is appropriate for this area
but it will respond well to the context
and result in
an interesting variety of buildings and
forms and sites
we think an attractive high quality
environment can be delivered
and the design intents are set out in
the applicant's submission
we think is excellent and that can be
secured by condition
so moving on to access and movement
the main vehicular access to the site is
here in the northeast corner of
uh talbot road along there the um
the sort of uh magenta line there and
this dark blue
uh these dark blue arrows here show the
the main
uh access point for the only vehicular
access point
and the vehicle egress point
pale blue line here is the cycle lane
that's proposed by tfgm
uh under the funding that they've got
and then within the sites
um the the idea is to try and contain
most of the parking within a
multi-storey car park here denoted by
this uh dotted
black line but notwithstanding that
um there would be there would need to be
access within the site for
deliveries and servicing and emergency
routes
and that's shown by the solid green line
now it's anticipated that any smaller
delivery vehicles would would egress
out back through uh and onto tolbert
road
whereas larger vehicles uh would access
onto brian statham way and then back out
onto the highway network at the existing
junction of brian statham way
and tolbert road idea is that
brian statham way is largely
pedestrianized
but and it would only be a small number
of vehicles that would have to egress
from the site
and use that that existing junction
there
so that's the access and movement
proposal within
within the site
school drop off um the um
the anticipation there is that um
there would be some short stay uh on
street parking days
created on tolbert road should the
school come forward
of course there's no suggestion that the
school has to come forward on this site
um it could be an offset
um and then there would be a walking
route through to
school here it's also accepted that
because of the
the proximity of the site to airs road
and warwick road south on the other side
of the tram line
but you could well get parents wanting
to drop children off
in that area walk across the tram line
and into the school here
and whilst that's likely to have some
impact
um the thinking there is that with the
traffic regulation orders and traffic
monitoring that's required
under the recommended section 106
agreement any impact that that had could
be
could be managed and and mitigated
um just going back to the
um the accessor movement we touched on
the car park here
and the fact that you know that is where
we want most of the cars to be
to be contained um the idea is that that
will be a 200 space
car park um of those spaces would be
split
between the various uses proposed on the
site
um there may well be some uh more
limited parking uh disabled parking for
example within the site
but the idea is that it's very much a
pedestrian-centered environment within
within the site in terms of
um any impacts that the
restricted level of parking might have
you know it is accepted obviously that
there's a
um seems in the report a significant
reduction
in terms of the overall parking numbers
relative to the maximum standards set
out
in in the trafford's in trafford's
parking guidelines um
but if there is to be any impact then
um you know residents i guess might look
to park on some of the surrounding roads
but we think that given the distance
of those roads from from the site
residents are very of the news of this
site are very unlikely to want to leave
their
cars parked overnight uh so far from
their homes
and in addition to that as i mentioned
those
suggestion that we can monitor the
on-site parking
uh that takes place and through traffic
regulation orders at the applicant's
expense
create residence only parking days where
residents from the new site would
probably be
prevented from parking on those other
surrounding roads
okay so just move on to phasing we have
received
a phasing plan um for the scheme i don't
know whether you can read the annotation
here on
on the right hand side of screen it's
anticipated that given the
the submission of the the lancashire
application for the
next for the new stand in the hotel that
that would probably be the first
phase of the development uh phase two
then we think would be
the car parking and the apartments up at
the northeastern corner of the site
uh phase three then perhaps the some of
the
uh residential blocks along brian
statham way
uh and then phase four some of the
townhouses
like to be family housing in this part
of the site
and then phase five moving back again in
the northeast
direction uh the school we we
understand we think that if that does
come on site that might be lost
as you may have read in the report
education their preference at the moment
is for um contributions to improve
existing schools in the area
and yet they do want to reserve judgment
on that and have the flexibility
um to have the school on this site if
um if that proves to be that the right
thing to do in
in the in time
okay so that that's that's the scheme um
uh rebecca's just gonna take over now
and take you
through the uh developer uh
contributions to the scheme
so i shall pause my microphone
rebecca
thanks david um okay um this table sets
out
all the uh developer contributions that
have been sorted
and that are being put forward by the
developer for all the various
mitigation that that's that's required
it's quite a lengthy section of the
report so we thought we would summarize
it in a table
for you and take you through it um so
the
the first on that list is that is
affordable housing
now in um strategic locations where a
site would perform
differently in viability terms to a
generic site
and then as a policy requirement of up
to 40
they're performing differently um
means in this in this instance is that
this is not a
entirely residential scheme this is very
much a mixed use scheme
so it can't reasonably be compared to
something which was bringing forward
um only uh residential development
uh the contribution that has been um
offered by the by the developer is 15
and for that provision to be on
on site um that will be subject to
a review mechanism so in in the
viability assessment
that's being put forward there are um
assumptions made because
they have to be based on some
assumptions around cost
of the development build and the sales
values which
um which might be obtained
now um if if those
costs are higher than anticipated and if
um or lower than anticipated with sales
values were
higher or lower then you could get to a
position
with lower costs and higher sales values
where
the profit made out of the scheme was
was greater than
um then was anticipating that was put
forward in the viability
uh assessment to come to the figure
contribution in that case um
the planning authority would be able to
capture that um
what we call super profit and and that
would be able to be directed
towards a additional affordable housing
either on site or um or elsewhere in the
borough and the detail of that would be
dealt with through
the 106. um we have robustly
together with our viability consultant
interrogated an
assessed development viability
assessment
and we are now entirely satisfied
that 15 is the maximum that could that
could be provided
alongside the other contributions with
which which i'll move on to
now in terms of the affordable housing
to be developed
and the mixture of unit types
would match those in development as a
whole so um
although it's an outline application we
don't know what that mix is at the
moment
there is a condition requiring a
proportion of those
units to be family homes we would expect
that the affordable housing as reserve
matters came forward
um had was of the same mix as
as that overall development in terms of
tenure
um that is uh to be determined and again
would be determined
through the section 106 agreement um in
terms of
its the appropriateness and the type and
again the types of units that were
that were coming forward um so if i move
on to open space now
and there's a significant amount of
public open space on the site given its
size
um which which we consider appropriately
serves this
type of high-density development um
however it does generate
a requirement contributions because our
open space standards are are based on
suburban style
low density development because that's
what we saw coming forward in the
borough
um and until recently when we've been
seeing these more high identity schemes
so they there are three open space
contributions
uh which which are required once a local
open space which would be off-site
once children's and young people's
facilities which would be off-site
and also one for outdoor sport
um in terms of local open space in
children and young young people you can
see on the table there
there's a 750 unit scheme that the
contributions of
um almost 170 000 pounds for local space
and
350 000 pounds for um children in young
people's facilities
um that that would be how much would be
would be
um contributed if if 750 units came
forward
that would be reduced proportionally if
if a lower number of units
came forward because it is of course an
up to um
outline application that's not
anticipated necessarily that the full
750 views would be
delivered but the formula allows for an
adjustment that
that would be policy com compliant
um for outdoor sport um sport england
have asked for contribution to outdoor
sport which is also required by our
supplementary planning
guidance but they've also asked for a
contribution to indoor sport
we have no policy requirement for indoor
sport so we can't carry that request of
sports segments forward
um but we've considered the outdoor
sport
contribution and determined through the
viability assessment that it that
it would not be viable to provide that
contribution of 820 000 pounds
however given the um
the contributions that the scheme is
making on site
and offsite through financial
contributions we do think that overall
when taken
you look at the scheme as a whole it
does appropriately contribute towards
open space
and is compliant with our development
plan policy
fight which requires that appropriate
contribution
but also that that should be looked at
in the round
um the next the next contribution to
talk about is education
the um development will obviously have
a residence and that will generate a
need for school places
particularly there are there are family
homes and that has been calculated
at 1.8 million for again for 718.
however as you've seen there is land set
aside
for a school on the site
so the contribution for um
towards education could either be the
land the school
um or it could be a financial
contribution
uh that school would be a two-form entry
primary school and would serve the wider
area
and just be for this particular site it
would be also for the development coming
forward
for the at the civic quarter and likely
at pomona as well
in terms of secondary school places
there's no requirement as there is
there are sufficient security school
places at lost stock
to meet the demand from this development
um
the the additional information report
clarifies
a point in the main report refers to an
equivalent contribution
towards the improvement of offsite
primary education facilities um
just to clarify the required education
contribution would be 1.8 million
it would not be um equivalent to the
value of the land on which
the school may be delivered which is
around 3 million
but it would represent the policy
compliant amount associated with the um
potential pupil yield so that that's on
that basis we have
we've assessed and um and deemed that's
to be acceptable
um also in terms of the school it
it's important to just set out the role
of the planning committee
here this evening um there will need to
be a decision in due course as to
whether
um to meet the demand for school places
in this area
uh that a new school is built on this
site
or or instead existing schools are
expanded
um but that's not a decision for the
planning committee that's not the
decision you're making this evening
on the merits of of those two options
that would be a decision
in due course for the executive however
your role this evening is to consider
whether a new school or the appropriate
education contribution in financial
terms would mitigate the impact
of demand for primary school places
which arise out of the development
so that's that's um that's the decision
that needs to be made in planning terms
this evening
um so moving on to health care on there
um there's a 300 000 pound contribution
for
um which is the equivalent to a one
new gp which has been uh requested by
the
ccg and just is to be um contributed
that again is policy compliant
and also for the processional route
there's a contribution
of uh circa a million um to go into the
professional route between
um the old trafford and warside tram
stops
effectively uh and uh and deal with uh
upgrades to public realm on brian
statham way
that exact amount needs to be determined
through the sexuality
agreement but it would be as i say
around a million pounds
um it's also worth noting that the
profit from
the scheme uh will be shared 50 50
between the council and with and
brentwood through the joint ventures
arrangements and therefore the council's
share of any profit
would be put into the capital programme
and into schemes which which would have
public benefit okay
thank you
thank you rebecca um i'm just going to
finish off now by
sort of summarizing the uh uh off
our views officers views on the scheme
as we would normally do um
with the introduction of a planning
application at committee
and also just fairly briefly talk you
through the
additional information report so why
don't i try and um
what a nice image of the development
back on the screen for you while i
i just go through through through these
points so
it's considered that the development
will create an attractive sustainable
mixed-use community
based around a new residential
neighborhood and local center
the premise of the scheme based around
low car ownership and usage
is considered to be an appropriate
response to the site's sustainable
location
and while slow parking provision is
intentionally well below the council's
maximum parking standards should any
harm arise through
car parking over spilling from the site
onto surrounding roads
scope for harm is considered to be
extremely limited
and can in any event be controlled by
commitment made to parking surveys and
traffic regulation orders set out and
draft section 106
heads of terms consider the variation in
maximum building heights across the site
is appropriate response responds well to
the context
and will result in an interesting
variety of building forms and types
scheme has been designed around a number
of attractive open spaces
and also includes contributions towards
the improvements of the wider public
rail
scheme also promises to deliver a 31
improvement on building regulation
targets in terms of energy use
whilst a small number of adverse impacts
have been identified
including the less than substantial harm
to heritage assets
potential minor ecological impact
on the lack of a financial contribution
towards offsite sports improvements
scheme delivers an extensive number of
benefits
the main benefits are listed at
paragraph 225
of the officer report but they include
the contribution the scheme will make to
the council's five-year housing land
supply
including the delivery of 15 of
affordable housing on site
with a viability review mechanism
the high quality development of a
previously developed site
in a highly sustainable location
and the regenerative benefits of the
scheme overall to which
substantial weight is given the suite of
policy compliant developer contributions
listed in the section 106 heads of terms
including those relating to health open
space and public realm improvements
in addition to the economic benefits of
the scheme
as well as the provision of a new
primary school or equivalent
contribution
significant weight is given to all of
these benefits
the developments level considered to
comply with the development plan
but having carried out the weighted
balancing exercise at paragraph
11 of the mppf it's considered that the
adverse impacts of granting to
buying permission would not
significantly and demonstrably outweigh
the benefits
of doing so indeed the benefits of the
scheme are considered to significantly
outweigh
the adverse impacts identified above
the application is therefore recommended
for approval
if i can just now also talk you briefly
through the additional information
reports
um the first point is one that rebecca
clarified a few minutes ago is that the
ccg have confirmed the off-site
health care contribution at 300 000
pounds
the applicant has agreed to that and
that would be secured through a section
106
obligation the additional information
report also sets out
public sector equality duty case law has
established that appropriate
consideration of equality issues
a requirement for local authorities in
the determination of many applications
with this requirement directly stemming
from the equality act in 2010
the applicant has provided a statement
which sets out how the application has
addressed matters of equality
mainly those relating to age disability
pregnancy and maternity
richer religion or belief race sexual
orientation gender reassignment
marriage and civil partnership this
notes that both organizations forming
the joint venture are fundamentally
committed to ensuring equality for all
promoting access to opportunities for
people to improve their lives
the proposals have been designed to
create a welcoming and inclusive
environment
minimal barriers to those persons with a
physical or other non-visible disability
all buildings and spaces will be
designed with ramps access points
and future adaptability possible where
necessary
whilst permission is sought in outline
only the design information submitted
makes it clear that a range of
residential accommodation types
will be provided including ground floor
accessible units
planning conditions are proposed to
secure details for inclusive access
including a minimum of 10 of the
residential units on site
being accessible disabled car parking
will also be built into the detail plans
which will come forward at reserve
matters stage
no persons would be prevented from using
the development due to being pregnant or
being a parent
or due to religion belief race culture
sexual orientation
gender or marital status families will
be actively encouraged
and as a part of the residential mix
family accommodation is proposed
open spaces and children's play
equipment will also be provided on-site
officers are satisfied that no dis
benefits have been identified in this
respect
and on this basis the design of the
proposal is considered to have
appropriately addressed
matters of quality finally there have
been
an update to a number of the conditions
on the officer report
those are conditions three phasing for
the revised height parameter plan
five hotel bedroom numbers six
requirement
to include monitoring of the provision
of accessible units
12 an accessibility statement 18 and 20
which relates to submission of
information at reserve matters stage
37 minor revision to the travel plan
condition
38 again a minor revision to the
electric vehicle charging point
condition uh thank you for your patience
that um
that concludes the uh the introduction
thank you shannon
i'll take i'll take the um the display
down here
thank you mr pearson um we have speaker
speaking for this application mr bailey
do we have mr bailey
yes if you'd like to speak mr bailey you
have three minutes thank you
good evening members my name is conor
valley and i'm the agent on this
planning application
the area around the lancashire cricket
ground including this site
has been a long-standing regeneration
priority for the council
today is a hugely important one for this
part of trafford
if members grant planning commission
then a vital step will have been taken
in kickstarting the delivery of the
council's objectives for the civic
quarter area action plan
the civic corridor seeks to deliver up
to 4 000 sustainable new homes
employment green space and community
usages over the new
local plan period and beyond it is an
ambitious flagship proposal
on one of the largest regeneration lead
master plans in the north of england
the founding principles of this
development fully accorded with the
civic quarters objectives
and that it will be truly sustainable
and inclusive to all
the site is exceptionally well connected
to sustainable transport options
being adjacent to the metrolink and
plugged directly into the talbot road
cycleway the key benefits of the
application include
example our sustainability and
architecture which will set new
standards in greater manchester
delivery of up to 750 much-needed new
homes
making a significant contribution to the
council of supply including accessible
and family accommodation
15 affordable housing on site according
to 112 homes
creating over 2 000 jobs through
construction and a further circuit 250
jobs on site through new office
development
as you have heard a site for a new
primary school new area is a public
publicly accessible open space
an energy center new cafes restaurants
and community facilities
and the significant package of section
106 contributions
of well over 1 million pounds in
addition to the community infrastructure
levy
members can be assured of rapid progress
should permission be granted
with the joint applicant committed to
the early submission of reserve matters
development viability has been robustly
tested as you have heard
and a reappraisal mechanism is to be
secured by legal agreement
your officers have concluded this
development will accelerate delivery of
the civic quarter
and granting consent today would add
real momentum to that process
in summary the application complies with
the development plan
and will deliver significant social
economic and environmental benefits for
this part of the borough
importantly there are no technical
objections the committee report
comprehensively addresses all of the
material considerations
and we would like to thank officers for
their hard work
i'd also like to thank you for your time
and we respectfully request members to
consent in line with her recommendation
thank you
thank you mr bailey um council minister
has got a question
thank you chair um
my question is um about so if
should the school not be built because
obviously we don't yet know if school
would be built or not
uh should it not be built would the uh
percentage of 15
stand for the affordable housing or
would it go up or down
um this next question which is also kind
of links in i guess
together with it is given um current
ways that we're going we're going
towards going away from having
offices in that way because uh due to
covert and more
working from home um is it necessary to
have that many
off you know office buildings and could
they be more
affordable housing in there so they're
my my sort of
linked questions thank you uh
miss coley or mr pearson like to answer
that
um i could i can take the take the
question
both the questions but both the
questions are on
the contributions effectively so um i i
can take those
in terms of the um the school
and whether you would um have the land
or
contribution if if you took the
contribution
then the review mechanism would be
picking up any super profit
so if as a result of that the developer
made more profit
then we would pick that up review it
would not
um it would not make any difference to
the
15 in terms of that coming down that is
a minimum
could it go up it could go up yes
and could we encourage that uh that
that depends entirely on whether uh on
on what profit is made from the scheme
so it would be based on on the actual
profit made
okay what about the offices has any
considerate consideration being given to
the fact that now we've had the pandemic
and what's
obviously changed what the new normal is
um well i'm not not i don't think we can
say with any certainty and certainly
the decisions that coming out the
planning inspector are not
uh trying to say that anything's changed
permanently
but we have to deal with the application
which is in front of us which is for
officers
should should there not be a market for
offices is an outline application
parameters plans it isn't up to so that
could come forward for something else
it's necessarily going to be housing or
affordable housing because
anything that's built on the site needs
to make a commercial return
so again it would be a proportion of
that that might come forward as a
housing yeah yeah
you know i understand it'll be a
proportion so the the number may go up
but it wouldn't be the proportion that
would go up the percentage may well stay
the same is that what you're saying
yes so so the the maximum of 750 does
assume
um that the office blocks are not office
blocks in our residential units
ah okay okay okay i understand thank you
thank you rebecca thank you council
administ councillor jerome
[Music]
thank you jim um yeah this
is uh a real big application and quite
an important one thing
i think you know it's on a big
brownfield site
and we know in this borough that we have
to use our brownfield sites
and we know about the tilted balance and
and the contribution of accommodation
that we need in the borough in terms of
the land supply
um and we know that this is an outline
application as
as well but i think overall i tend to be
quite favorable towards it i think it's
got great green aspirations running
throughout this application
um it seeks to move away from car
dependence
and i think that could form a real
blueprint for how we do applications
as we step up our ambition to meet our
carbon targets in the in the future
and also to meet kind of gm's five-year
environmental plan
so i just wanted to quickly uh mention
some of the good things i think that are
in this application
such as the treat the trees and the
landscaping there's plans to
minimize the tree loss um to keep that
green urethra out
um and make sure that trees that do come
down are replaced
i think the affordable housing is very
commendable
um trafford i think has been
quite robust with its affordable housing
over the last few years and i think they
have been here too we know this is a
cold market location
um which is described in policy l2
um and we know we are in good market
conditions but to
um move the requirement up to 15 i think
it
it is applaudable and one i support i
think it will be good
i also like the energy statement um i
think having an energy center on there
um is a very very positive thing
um and we don't usually see this with
with applications
um so it's looking to promote a kind of
decentralized infrastructure
it would deliver renewable and low
carbon carbon energy schemes
um through heat and energy network
opportunities
and that's obviously gonna you know
help our five-year environment plan um
and i think um you know the thermal heat
pumps
could be a great way of providing energy
energy for the homes
and the other buildings on site but
there's also some asparagus
aspirational things mentioned in there
such as green roofs
and if you've got green roofs you could
possibly have beehives on there
um and get community engagement in that
way
um but also it will help with the the
flooding
and then the the lead local authority
does um
is in favor of this application and
propose some of the things that might
happen in the drainage scheme
such as um permeable paving
geo cellular storage uh cell storage of
rain water
for the gardens it talks about um
pipes and roof gardens which will
obviously stop
water kind of displacement onto onto the
land
um so i think it does a a number of
really good things in terms of flooding
and green infrastructure
um i'd also agre agree with the
applicant in their their response to
highways england
um who have used the tricks analogous at
the tricks data to show that the school
might have a 59
drop-off rate um but if you actually
look at the location it's on
and you you know there's much more there
for walking to school
and for parents not using the car so so
i think the applicant actually rubbed up
some of the
the highway england points that have
been made and highway
highways england have actually come back
and um removed their objection i i
believe
um so overall i think this is quite a
good um
application i really like it's our
aspiration
and i'd be interested to hear what other
members think
before making my final decision so uh
thank you chair thank you councilwood
jerome councillor hartley
uh thank you chair i mean i i echo a lot
of what uh councillor
jerome said in terms of the you know the
positive features of the
of the development that's um that's
proposed in in in this one application
um i'd i'd commend the officers for
putting together a really good uh
report really good detailed report but
also commend them for
you know securing the commitment to 15
affordable housing
you know i think that's that's really
good given the site and given the
conditions and i think the you know the
commentary and also the summary which
uh miss carla presented tonight about
the developer contributions i also think
uh was really helpful and i think is a
real a real positive
uh positive aspect of the of the
application
i i think i think it's a i think it's a
good scheme in us in as far as we can
tell it given it's a an outline
application
um it's obviously a brownfield site i
think it makes good use of the site
there's a good mix
of of uses um up to 750 houses obviously
makes a really important contributions
to to trafford's uh housing supply
where we know where we're behind we're
behind schedule
and what's proposed is a you know a good
diversity of housing but also
smaller affordable housing and we've
seen the condition as well around
a portion of of houses that are suitable
for families so i think that's really
welcome
i think the the local services um
i agree with the report they're they're
an essential part of the scheme really
so
i agree with the with the um the
commentary on the sequential test i
think having those local services
there as part of the scheme is an
essential part of it
and i really welcome the concept of
what's what's proposing the development
of having
a car free um car free neighborhood or
predominantly car free
neighborhood pedestrianized with a you
know a separate
car parking garage at the corner of the
site
you know that that has a real sort of
european feel that's the sort of thing
that
is being done in you know germany
denmark and elsewhere where they will
you know they will build whole towns and
villages on that sort of concept
so i think i think it's really welcome i
think it's really welcome so i don't
have any concerns about about the
parking
um and i also welcome you know the
environmental
uh aspirations which which councillor
jerome describes you know the
zero carbon target uh the the energy
center i think that i think they're
really welcome as well
so i'm i'm supportive of the scheme and
and um
i have i have two reservations um
i think at this stage but but i think
that these will be picked up
or could be picked up and considered
when the applications
uh come forward for the reserve matters
one is about the building heights um
you know i really sort of applaud the
efforts to minimize the impact on on the
heritage assets in the area
and have this stepped approach of of
building heights as you go towards the
sort of east along along talbot road
that that makes sense i think um
the maximum height and i know they are
maximum heights but but the aspiration
is for
a high density development here um
of 20 stories or 15 stories along
the along the elevation that faces
tolbert road so i think we saw from
uh mr pearson's presentation you know
about about sort of half of that
talbot road frontage could be 15 to 20
stories
um and 20 stories is much higher than
any other buildings in the immediate
intermediate area
and so my my reservation about that is
having
having that amount of you know that
degree of
high buildings on that elevation
alongside the buildings that are on the
other side of talbot road
oakland house and uh and the other
buildings that are along their little
town hall
that that could create quite a um sort
of a canyon feel to talbot road
which you know um i know you see a lot
of in in sort of manhattan and sort of
city centers but i think sometimes that
can
be quite claustrophobic but i think i
think the um
the report comments on that and it and
it does um it
it does paragraph 84 it does comment on
that and and
say that in reality it wouldn't be
acceptable to have a
a very tall continuous frontage along
tolbert road
and i think that's right so certainly i
would want to see that
you know that that sort of um elevation
broken up so that at least if you've got
very tall buildings there is
open space in between to sort of reduce
what might be a claustrophobic feel
my other reservation came to the jerome
uh mentioned which is about the
the drop-off zones to the north and the
south um
i i can understand the reasons for
suggesting those as part as part of the
design
um given the you know given the
proportion of
of pupils that arrive by car at primary
schools in the area
there are other primary schools in the
area and i realized that the school
may not be built you know in which case
there wouldn't really be a need for
those drop-off zones
but even if the school does end up being
built to provide those drop-off zones
does
seem to run counter today to the design
concept to me that you're
you're coming up with a pedestrianized
development where you don't want people
to drive but you are
providing facilities for pupils to be to
be driven to school
i know the reality is a lot of people's
are driven to school but i think the
aspiration should be that
if a primary school is built there the
catchment is likely to be pretty small
and the aspiration should be that those
pupils would walk to school and and you
don't provide the um the drop off zones
but it's a difficult balance because i
you know except if you didn't provide
anything
then you might end up with dangerous
parking on on wl lines and
and in residential areas and the like so
i think i think it'd be useful if when
the application for reserve
matters is made if if if some thought
could be given to that in the travel
plan and and you know there could be
more aspiration
uh about that and about in in sort of
so that it was consistent with the
design concept um
for the scheme as i understand it but um
but those those are matters which um
which in my view sort of prevent any
obstacle
at this stage and i agree with the the
officer's recommendation
um the adverse impacts such such as they
are
are are clearly outweighed by you know
the considerable benefits
to this to this scheme so um you know
the harm that's
caused is less than substantial so i'd
agree with the officer recommendation
um to to be minded to to grant the
application
um and and um the final thing i'd say is
uh
you know i also welcome the the detailed
conditions
you know which um you know which make up
a lot of the report
um but again they're really welcome
because they deal with
um you know a lot of reservations that
there might be about the scheme going
forward but
but i really welcome the scheme i think
it's a really good innovative scheme um
that's going to make a
you know a good contribution to
trafford's housing supply so i'm i'm
supportive of the application chair
thank you
thank you councillor hartley um
councilwoman stanley you'd like to speak
yeah thank you chair i think there's
there's a pattern emerging and what
we're all saying tonight
is that the um there's an awful lot
in this scheme to recommend it to
i love the fact it's designing out the
car except when cars are needed for
reason disability i love the locations
brownfield sites
a little bit surrounded by public
transport
um i love the uh the developer
infrastructure contribution but where
fifty percent fifty percent
expect nothing less really and i also
like the fact that the
public sector equality duty has been
referenced in the um
information which is fantastic as far as
as far as i'm concerned
i do have some reservations though um
and the first one is quite an odd one
bearing in mind i love the fact that
this is designing out the car
uh and it is around the car parking
space
because what's referenced when we're
talking about this is
uh in section 107 i think i think it's
comparing this development to all the
developments
in the in manchester where there are no
cars
um and it's not an issue there and i
know these developments because a
couple of my grown-up kids live in them
but this is a different
sort of development this is aimed for
families the center of manchester is
aimed
for people without children which is one
thing and one thing you notice in all
the new development center manchester
there there are very very few children
and i think once when you've got
families with
uh with kids cars become more essential
and i know this is kind of an entire
contradiction when you're trying to
design out the car
but i wonder what will happen when
you've got 750 up to 750
um households with only 200 car parking
spaces
and that that concerns me
uh the second reservation is around
the um the design and access statements
and i said
we have we we had our uh a longer
session for
uh members earlier in the week um
and it is to do with disabled
accessibility
because in the design and access day
which does refer to
uh diverse and inclusive homes which are
safely inclusive for people of all ages
and it talks about
elsewhere about this being a development
development
for people between the ages of eight and
eighteen and that to me says that all
the homes should be homes for life
um so they if they if they're if all
homes if they're
not accessible now should be adaptable
and i noticed that some
when the developer spoke they referred
them to
um future ad up to the
adaptability um when necessary i'd be
very interested when this goes forward
to see what that
what that uh what that actually means
um because when we talk about the uh
houses which will be built which will be
accessible from the start we're still
talking about the old building rigs
minimum 10 and i think particularly as
we are the
50 percent the developer on this maybe
we have a
higher aspiration along those lines
the final reservation was i
listen all the time to the uh the
viability assessments and how we work
our temperatures how much the housing
should be affordable
and i get that 15 is more than you would
normally expect
in a development like this but i come
back against what i said earlier in the
week
um as we move forward through this
application is that we are fifty percent
of the developer on this
and i i can't but think that we can
uh we can have a a more ambitious plan
for the um
for the affordable housing as we should
have a more ambitious
ambitious plan to make the uh the
developments
accessible um but tonight
on the basis this is all about just
allowing access to the side yeah i'll be
supporting it i think so
i think it's got the base of naturally
fantastic developments thank you chair
thank you councillor win stanley um can
i say i think that that first point you
raised about
about car parking councilman i think
perhaps
jeff everson could could answer that
perhaps the other two items
issues you have will be more dealt with
in the reserve matters when we get down
to the
specific detail later on but um i know
if jeff could you comment on on that on
that parking that
inevitably there will be a greater
demand for parking you know 200 parking
spaces
whereas previously we might have said it
needed 2 000 car parking spaces
um could you comment yeah evening
everyone
and yeah in terms of the car parking has
been mentioned
already today tonight regarding the
sustainability of the site
and the aspirations of the council and
the ambitions of
changing people's concepts and the way
they travel
and there will inevitably be some
pressures
possibly as the development proceeds but
we're comfortable that
by introducing additional restrictions
in the local area
for which the developers accepted um a
section 106
obligation the any
any shortfall in parking any crashes on
parking
in the local on the local highway
network can be addressed by introducing
other restrictions um because it does
strap
the commitment is there to cover a one
kilometer
walking area and so it's quite a wide
area
around the development and we feel that
that in itself can address any problems
which we
which we may have in in the years to
come
okay um council win stanley are you
happy with that
answer from uh from jeff councillor
yeah so sorry sorry to interrupt council
washer
i was just going to add to what mr
edenson had said but
um in the recommendation uh condition 11
which is on page
bottom of page 63 of your agenda
it includes it requires that any reserve
matters applications to be accompanied
by a parking
management strategy for that phase but
part of the details that we want to see
our parking spaces will be allocated so
i think
you know that in terms of the concern
about perhaps
families being more in need of parking
spaces than
that's that's perhaps say some younger
people without families might live in
some of the apartments that are being
proposed on the site
and it might be that the houses and the
mansion blocks where you might get the
families living then
i think that's one way of trying to
address that issue
and that we try we look to ensure that
those parking spaces
are very an appropriate proportion of
them a proportional
proportion of them at least excuse me
are given
or to to the family units yeah okay
thanks because it's because because
something else something else was
slightly assuaged my concern on this is
that
the people who buy the who buy the
properties on this side
will know what they're getting into if
that makes sense they'll know
um so that that also slightly swags it
as well it's just
smaller but yeah thank you for the uh
for the office of contribution thank you
thank you uh councillor williams you'd
like to speak
thank you uh chair and i have sort of
scribbled down some thinking
and i'm hoping that as a consequence of
other members have said it doesn't now
come across as being a bit repetitive
really
um i think that this is a different sort
of application than we're used to seeing
at committee and it's a different sort
of development than what we typically
get
in trafford um i think it's situated in
a part of the
borough that's undergoing change at
quite a rapid pace with
many of the former business units in the
area
switching over to sort of a residential
use i really feel that the plots
actually very ripe for development and
it could quite easily
harbor a mixed use of units between
residential business
um perhaps some retail
and i think that that component of it
so to suggest that there's going to be a
different sort of living and a different
sort of lifestyle at this development
um one that's less dependent on vehicles
and with a more diverse sort of
community
living there than you typically find in
developments that contain
family accommodation i quite like the
sort of families
living alongside perhaps younger
residents and like the prospect of
people
living in a way that promotes public
transport use and active
travel and let's be clear that you can
from this site
walk to major retail centers you can
walk to stratford
you can walk to chulton and you can walk
even into the city centre
um i think that the graphics provided by
the applicant and shown
in mr pearson's part of the presentation
indicate that this
really could be a high quality
development which enhances
the local area i feel reassured by
what are a very robust set of conditions
and i think other members have indicated
that they feel the same
and i truly hope that this development
can be delivered to
a good standard that that said i will
just reflect on some of the concerns i
have um
this is this is a large development and
i think it has the capacity to
quite fundamentally change the feel and
character of the local area
the buildings are potentially quite
densely placed within the plot
and some of them are very tall in scale
and i
am a bit worried if i'm being honest to
the rest about that reference to
20 story uh blocks i don't want to see
the sort of changes that we've seen in
manchester city center
slowly start to creep south into
trafford
and i think i agree with much of what
councillor hartley said in his
contribution
in that respect um that said um
when you look at the area there are a
number of other
relatively tall office blocks along
tolbert road
and i think the other reassuring factor
for me
is that there is not a particularly
large number of existing residential
properties that could be adversely
impacted by the development of some
taller buildings at the plot
um in respect of the affordable housing
offer
i want to say first of all that i am
pleased to see that the council's
managed to negotiate an increase in the
provision of affordable housing
included in the development and that as
is highlighted in paragraph 21
of the report um myself i think that
it is still a relatively low figure at
15
and that leaves me a little bit
disappointed however the the inclusion
of the
viability review mechanism referred to
in paragraph 167 of the report and
discussed
earlier by officers but that is somewhat
reassuring um i appreciate that the
breakdown of tony type is yet to be
determined
um however i'd just like to say at this
point i really hope that
um when it is determined later on in
the development uh there can be an
emphasis perhaps
on uh affordable rent rather than just
shared ownership and i've said that i've
spoken to that effect
at different committee meetings because
i think um
really shared ownership tends to be the
preferred option we see from developers
and it's not what we need delivered in
the bubba to rebalance our housing
supply
um having said that it is clear
from the detail in the office of report
that there are extensive other developer
contributions with this
application um i thank ms curley for
summarising those during the
part of her during her part of the
presentation that we had earlier this
evening
um in respect of the educational school
provision
question i think i'm happy to accept the
the contribution negotiated be it a
school albeit financial is acceptable
my preference would be for the school to
actually be built
um i agree i think with the sentiments
expressed by councillor jerome
uh in his contribution in that i like
that we
are delivering a larger number of
residential units
are a large number of residential units
on a brownfield site
and beyond that i think there are a
number of other additional measures that
enhance the
sustainability of this development
reference to the energy center that's
the reference to sporting provision
upgrades to the processional route so on
and so forth and you know
that they were really quite adequately
summarized in the
office of reports so as such i think i
agree with the conclusion that's been
made by
our planning department that when you
look at this on balance there is more to
be gained from approving this
application
than from refusing it so as such i don't
think that the
uh application's actually been formally
proposed or seconded
yeah as i understand it so i'm happy to
do so in the interest of
moving business along tonight thank you
chad thank you councillor williams um
councillor morgan wants to ask a
question and comment but i just want to
bring in mr pearson to comment on the
mix of
of uh of social housing affordable
housing rather mr pearson
thank you chairman yeah i just wanted to
clarify the the policy position
in that regard so the core strategy
policy
l2 that that suggests that really we
should be looking at a 50
shared ownership provision of the
overall number of units
and then a 50 uh proportion for rent and
that would be a mix of
affordable rent and social rent
so that that's what we would push as as
officers um
when the affordable housing units came
forward obviously
as council is joint venture if it wants
to
put forward a different mix then then
that's something that we'll obviously
consider
thank you mr pearson i'm going to go to
councillor morgan
and have you still got your question
councillor morgan
i can't hear councillor morgan can
anybody else here councillor morgan
can you hear me now yes yes yes we can
yes we can cancel morgan we can hear you
it went straight to uh straight to uh
mute on my laptop follow just that i'll
just bring it through my comments that's
all right
chair okay
it's your your turn to speak councillor
morgan thank you
please do um thank you chair um
so i think there's some real positives
on this development and to be honest
with you i looked at it the first time i
looked at i thought i i really think
really positively and that's generally
how i
um looks at it even now there's a real
focus on the civic quarter
um there's some green there's some
fantastic parts in terms of green
developments
energy efficiency um in terms of the
developer contributions it's a
brownfield site and it's got a real
range of houses
and i think generally kind of my view in
terms of with school as well
and i really do hope that we do get a
new score on
on this site um i know it's not decided
as uh miss cowley will um say but
um um it it's it
it's it's a real community and i think
that's a real positive
quite often i feel like we we approve
developments and we're tagging houses or
a couple of houses or a small
development on top of it
on top of an estate and ignoring the
fact that we need a community and
services and and all of the
extras that make do you mean where you
make a make a home you don't just buy a
house in a
in a set of houses it's the community
around the you you buy it around
um i i disagree with some of the
previous comments in terms of in terms
of for example the height
and i'm going to disagree with
councillor williams here about his
center i really like the fact that the
the height of the city center though i
do agree with him
i wouldn't want it out as far as here um
but um and i don't agree with him or
council heartland in terms of
it's negative in terms of the height
around here i think actually
it's the area to to put the height if
we're going to put any in
in in the borough um and then the
school's drop-offs i think council
hartley kind of answered his own
conundrum there that if we don't put
these score drop-offs
um areas around it we are just going to
create a problem that's
far far worse um and i but i do
understand his kind of point
um i'm going to actually agree and i
won't make a habit of
agreeing with council win stanley though
there were one reservation about this
which is about the parking um i
i i have real concerns and i i know uh
miss evans and um as
miss pearson have made comments about
what that we will be making plans
further on along the line
if this gets approved in terms of
looking about the management of the car
parking spaces but i've lived in a
development outside the city centre
where there wasn't enough um parking
spaces
and it can cause chaos
and it requires a real lot a lot of work
not just in the initial stages
been working in terms of when flats
thing they may get rented out
and developer and the and the estate
agents say there's one with the parking
space then later on
you find actually it doesn't and i think
i'm i am it's definitely not a reason to
object i will be voting in favor of this
development tonight
but i do is my one concern is i've seen
it happen in the past
i've experienced it myself and it it can
cause real issues
um and i do i do appreciate that the the
traffic
management schemes the parking
management schemes will be a significant
area around it but
if you too many people have cars they
will find a place to park it
just because they've got to find
somewhere to park it and it is a concern
of mine
but that being the one concern i've got
um
i will be supporting this tonight and i
am i'm really really pleased to see it
thank you thank you councillor morgan
councillor procter you'd like to speak
uh thank you chair i'm i'll be pretty
brief really because
most of the other counselors have said
what i was gonna say really and
i'm also very much in favor of the
scheme
i think it's um the plans are really
good
good design and it's a good nice feel to
it it's kind of
mediterranean in a sense and lots of
green spaces and i think it would be
it would be a good place to live there
are some negative
aspects of as we've heard from other
councils but i think they're
they're vastly um overweight by the
the benefits of it i think it would be
really act towards we regenerate the
area
and it will improve um
the physical and the um
structure of the the area and and a
great feel to it
i was also very concerned about the
parking of the the site i mean we having
which we want it to be
a car free zone the reality is that
people like
the foreseeable future people are gonna
have cars and i think that's gonna cause
a lot of problems for those particulars
constant morgan
as outlined it's going to cause
difficulties that are going to need to
be
addressed as we move forward um
my other concern is about the potential
for congestion in the area and that we
haven't mentioned that one so far
i think it's if you look at the area
currently it's it's a highly congested
area and you know we did extra
numbers of people and cars coming now
it is going to have some some impact
i know we've had some um
satisfaction uh reports from the
highways authorities saying that they
they're satisfied with it and
it's not going to be an issue and
there's going to be things that mitigate
that
but i still think that could be
potentially long-term an issue
the uh affecting the highly congested
area
nearby um so that's one thing that we
haven't raised so far
and uh it is a slight concern the other
one is
obviously on the affordable housing i
think 50 percent isn't great to be
honest
but it's the best we're going to get
under these circumstances and there is a
possibility
that might increase so i'd be happy to
live with that
so overall um some concerns
but i will be voting in favor of it i
think it will be
a huge benefit to the area and
we'll create a a nice place for people
to live
with a mix mixed community of young
people and families
and so i will support it thank you
thank you councillor procter um mr
pearson you wanted to come in
about highways mr pearson
thank you councillor yes sorry it was
just another park rather parking sorry
mr
parking yeah it was just one further
point i should have mentioned earlier
actually
uh and that is the in the the
applicant's uh
travel plan um they did um
i don't identify the possibility of of
using car clubs
you know in in certain phases of the
development so these can work well
in in sort of high density uh
developments um you know where people
can effectively
car share and just rent a car when they
need one rather than having one parked
up all the time so
i mean that's issues sort of tied up
with the travel plan
condition we've got but obviously when
schemes come forward at reserve matters
stage
then that issue could be looked at so if
that's some comfort to members i just
thought i'd mention that
yeah um mr evanson
would would you like to comment about
that the highway the extra
if you like load of traffic on talbot
road for uh for council proctor
yeah fine yeah in terms of um the extra
traffic
the fact that we're reducing the amount
of
car parking on the site and the
encouragement of sustainable travel
then it's not expected that it will
generate as much
traffic as what members may consider it
would would do
but equally the um the corridor
in the area action plan which is
currently being worked up and the
aspirations for talbot road
in that talbot road will be reduced in
terms of traffic on the road
and traffic diverted on to the a56 so
in during the life of the development um
there are aspirations to improve the
environment
and reduce the amount of traffic in
immediately in and around the talbot
road
and so we didn't see that the the
development itself
the proposal would have a severe impact
on the local network
okay thanks for that uh mr evanson
um councilman jerome you had a question
you'd like to pull
um pearson stole my sunder a little bit
because i was just
gonna say one of the possible solutions
to to the parking problem
would be to have a an ev car club
and um not only an ev car club but if
you've got the pv solar units on the
roof you could charge the
uh ev cars from the from the roof and
that would be a great solution
uh to the parking problem and uh you
know it would be generating its own
enemy energy and would be a very green
solution so
hopefully that could be considered and
brought forward hopefully
okay anybody else wishing to speak who
hasn't spoken perhaps
castle rigby yes please yes thank you
very much indeed um
i'll try not to repeat what's been said
um
but this is quite obviously an exciting
outline planning application um
of course all applications that come
before us are important but this
application is significant
as it forms part of the jigsaw um
of the exciting vision for the area
and with the civic quarter which has
been said
i've read the report several times and
um
white council half they recognize the
amount of detail
and time that officers spent and i think
we should
lose sight of that in supporting the
recommendation which i do i hope it
will will ultimately see an
award-winning
development and one that will stand the
test of time
i think that is key as we all know
this area has certain
has already benefited by certain
developments namely the town hall
and the cricket club you know um
whilst i appreciate that both these
developments attracted
a certain amount of opposition at the
time both have proved to be significant
not only benefiting the local area
but um the borough of trafford as a
whole
i appreciate that this is an outline
application but i'd like to stress the
importance
of ensuring that there's provision for
the land
to be retained to build a new two-form
entry primary school
i appreciate of course that this
decision will be taken ultimately by the
executive
but i think it's essential that the the
provision of land
is retained i say this not only because
of the large number of family dwellings
that are built to be built on the site
because it but because of the site
itself
which hasn't been mentioned is a virtual
island yeah should there not be a
primary school built up
on the site parents with young children
including infants
will have to attend existing schools
well that will then tell them crossing
the metrolink line walking across the
rails
or across talbot road at peak times and
this is not ideal this is not ideal when
we've got a wonderful opportunity yes i
appreciate
existing schools may be looking to
develop and provide
funds to improve and increase the size
of their current schools
and but i really hope that to make this
development complete the two-form entry
school
will remain an option but i will
certainly
be supporting the application
thank you councillor rigby councillor
stennett you'd like to comment
you're on mute councillor stannet just
unmute yourself
there we go
sorry it's councillor stanley you've
muted yourself again
very easily done okay
that's great that's great i'm going to
be brief
i think that this application takes all
the boxes
terms of both the short and long-term
benefits
to the area affordable housing
good examples education pleasure
and green roots i do not believe
that anything else could be put in place
especially when we look at the
developing
of a civic quarter that would be in
keeping
with preserving the historic values
and the fusion of new ideas to enhance
the area
i am not sure at this moment if i would
want to support a pub
as it as is recommended
i would rather look at seeing
smaller facilities that provide
meals and drinks run by people from the
community
i think that by and large it is an
excellent application making trafford
a good place to live work and play
and with that i'm quite happy to support
the recommendation
thank you councillor stennett councillor
minis you'd like to come in
yeah um i know that it's obviously an
outline application
there's a couple of things i don't know
whether we can sort of
so seeds for the future and i was just
thinking obviously uh with council
jerome saying about
pv uh panels and eevee charging um it's
a thing that's close to my heart i have
pv panels and
an electrical vehicle as well so what i
was going to also ask is
is there any chance of having of um
so on the sustainability side things
like gray water harvesting
from rainwater these things that we
could uh potentially bring in
and i was i really really like actually
counselors
then it's uh um you know suggesting that
i i also not
not very fan of the pub idea but having
something that's more community based i
think
would be um a better idea i would like
the school to be built on
on the site as well um because we have a
shortage of
school places for children as there is
in in trafford and i think it would
uh definitely help towards that um
so that that was that was all but i
quite like the
i quite like a lot of it i like the fact
that it's trying to keep
the cars out of the streets to allow
children to play in the streets and that
may make it safe for them
so i i like there's lots of it i like
and it's lots have already been said
about that but i just wanted to try and
sew some seeds into hopefully what what
will be developed into a brilliant place
it's called
yes of course if i could uh refer
councillor minutes and the other and the
other members to condition 15
um any any reserve matters application
relating to appearance needs to be
accompanied by a strategy for energy
efficiency
a low or zero carbon technologies for
that
phase to demonstrate how carbon
emissions of at least 30 percent below
building regulations
target emission rate should be achieved
so it is
built in to the reserve matters
applications
thank you for that miss coley i think
we've had a good discussion on this and
uh it's been proposed uh and seconded
council williams and councillor harvey
that we grant this application so i'll
go through
the voting procedure um councillor
williams how would you like to vote
uh vote in favor of application in line
with officer recommendation
thank you councillor stennit how would
you like to vote favor of the
application chair
thank you councillor morgan
council morgan can you hear me
tonight sorry about that and i'm i'm in
favor of officer recommendations
thank you councillor minis
in favor of some recommendation thank
you thank you councillor
stanley uh thank you chad in favor of
officer recommendation
thank you councillor procter
what's the recommendation to grant thank
you
councillor hartley thank you chair in
favor of the officer's recommendation
thank you councillor rigby how would you
like to vote of the officer's
recommendation
thank you councillor jerome i uh also
support
the recommendation thank you councillor
dr barkley do we have counsellor dr
barclay
yes you do and i support the officer's
recommendation to grounds
thank you councillor dr barkley and i'll
be voting in favor
so that is unanimous that's an easy one
for me to count and uh
that's 11 votes in favor of this
application none against
that application has been granted okay
we'll go to the next item
if i can find it on my
agenda papers
that's page 76 uh 92 to 94
park road and we have an introduction
from miss milner
thank you sir i will just share my
screen with you so you can see the
presentation
[Music]
there we go okay
right
can you all see that yep that's good
is that clear yes so the next
application
before you relate to 92-94 park road in
simply
the application comprises a vacant
commercial unit formerly used as a bank
the corner um
units um like you can see on your screen
highlighted
and from
onto parkway visualizations onto
hawthorne avenue
planning permission was granted in 1985
the change of use of the units for bank
and ancillary office space
and the planning commission included a
condition that restricted the use
of the premises to a bank prohibiting a
change of use under committed
development
the restriction was imposed at the time
to prevent the establishment of general
office used within the parade of shops
the current application seeks to remove
the kitchen
to allow the premises to be used more
flexibly and change the use
from a bank under permitted development
the application is reported to
committee as we have received more than
six objections and we have also
if you're calling from councillor brophy
um concerns raised by local residents
are detailed in your report
but do focus on um impacts on amenity
parking coming and going and
serving deliveries um amongst other
things
the key issue for officers is the
acceptability of removing the condition
and the impact that would have on the
local centre and the impact it would
have
on residential communities as well as
the impact on the local highway network
and parking so
officers have considered the application
in full and all the comments received
and it is worth noting that this is a
variation in application that was
approved in 1985
and since then a lot has changed in in
planning policy
and significant changes in fact and
most recently we've seen changes to the
use class order
and just a couple of months ago that
came in before in september
um which took to provide greater
accessibility on our high streets for
premises premises to change use without
formal planning commission
and we do support the removal of this
condition
to allow for and a change of use for the
premises to kind of
allow an investment opportunity to take
place however
with related changes we have seen the
introduction of
a now class e um expands upon the
previous a classes in allowing what
would be you
what would be permitted and for the unit
to change to
and we're not looking at a retail use
or a bank use we are looking at uses
that include clinics
and nurseries and these are you know
detailed in europe because of that
and officers have considered the impact
of all these uses and that would be
permitted
should this current condition be removed
and therefore we have without
conditions and as these body reports
that cover a range of issues and they
are
amenity of residents and also
to facilitate um further details on
um delivery and servicing arrangements
and those conditions have been imposed
because this condition
um its application seeks to remove the
condition it isn't
applying for a specific use for being
classy
it has been an additional information
report that you should all
have in front of you which details
further comments have been received
since the publication of the committee
report
the main comments on the applicant and
the agent
whilst they support the recommendation
of officers to approve the
the removal of this condition and you
raise
concern about the conditions proposed
and they have reiterated those comments
to me
and this afternoon and concerned that
they have now signed a contract for
a convenience store and a retail use and
vessel they are concerned that the
conditions we have imposed
would would hind that use um
i must be clear that because this
application
is not for a specific use but was put to
us
as allowing greater flexibility with
rain diseases we
feel that those conditions are set out
protect the amenity of president
and however similar to the conditions of
details in your good to
recommend approval thank you
thank you miss milner um councillor
brophy is here to speak
against this application councilor
brophy
you have five minutes councillor brought
me
[Music]
first things to unmute yourself
manage that bit okay so i'm speaking on
this planning application today not only
is the local council representing the
simply ward
but also i've had an overwhelming amount
of correspondence from local residents
since it was proposed to have a cost
cutter on this site
in addition a local resident having
lived
for over 20 years off park road very
close to the site of the planning
application
so unfortunately the food store
application going big travel council
licensing in
march despite strong objections from
local residents in the immediate area
and i hope that this current planning
application
enables something for this site that's
more in keeping with residents wishes
for the vacant 92 94 park road
so as we've seen in the report there's a
petition signed by 114 properties
objecting to the proposed food store and
the objections and the reasons can't be
ignored and must be taken seriously
and in addition we've seen that 10
residents have also submitted their
views to this committee and many many
more have communicated directly with me
and with the residents who will be
speaking tonight and all the points
mentioned
in this planning report from residents
remain validated
very valid in particular they feel that
the application has been quite
misleading for residents
and they're worried there's harm to the
safety of the building sits
very close to an already very dangerous
structure of park road
and the change of use it could prejudice
highway safety and these are why
residents have been very concerned about
this particular site
they have also reported to me that they
feel liaison with the applicant has been
quite poor with residents
and they've also said that they feel
there's been poor communication with
trafford council
so we know that parking issues in the
area are significant
and the impact on safety as part
vehicles on this site could lead to very
poor access for emergency vehicles
as we've said there was previously a
barclays bank on this site and if this
was nine to five
professional use and it's an amenity
that residents have had
since 1984 five that's 35 years
so the hour is now proposed at 8am to
8pm monday to sunday bank holidays and
public
holidays and i would hope that if this
has passed that lower hours are
considered at weekends
and that deliveries should not be during
the morning of rush hour
park road traffic is often backed up
beyond this point to the a56
and i've had feedback recently that some
residents are
accepting the new proposed hours of 8
a.m they are more acceptable and this
has passed
i would strongly urge these hours are
stuck to and not extended
and the hours should be as close as
possible to the hours that immediate
residents are accustomed to
so the planning application is to remove
conditions which currently only allow
the site to be used as a bank and for no
other purpose
and it's prevented from being used for
anything else so if this condition is
removed
whatever it is used for and there are
some things outlined in the report that
it says very much in keeping with
residents views and
it enhances the area and particularly
safety issues must be the heart of all
considered uses
traffic and parking are concerned the
early morning deliveries are a concern
and there's no real requirement for a
convenience store as has already been
said
and and residents are wishing to avoid
anything in the site that will increase
anti-social behavior in the area litter
in the area
parking is a major issue and we've just
had the new parking
and proposals in the area that have now
come forward
the residents really don't want any
traffic increases this
is close to a metrolink site road safety
is an issue as has been
mentioned nothing that would have large
vehicles or larry's coming because they
will struggle
this is hawthorne avenue is a road that
is on a hill
and it's very hard for vehicles to turn
around and large vehicles currently
cannot turn around along this side it's
totally inappropriate to have anything
that will
encourage big vehicles coming along this
road especially with emergency access
now there are sites very close to a
large primary school with a wide
catchment area
morning and afternoons at school
drop-off signs are already challenging
and we don't want anything that adds to
congestion and there are also
concerns about air pollution in the area
residents don't want to be disturbed by
late-night
noise or light disturbances due to
people parking outside and using their
driveways
so in summary as my time up comes on
behalf of local residents
if this is passed today i would strongly
urge that local residents views are
taken into account
and that along with local councillors we
are listened to
whatever is put forward to this site
local residents views must be taken into
account thank you very much
thank you councillor brophy um any
members wishing to comment
counselor minis would you like to come
in
yeah hi um thank you chair so
are there not any other speakers i
thought they might have been no is that
a okay
um so um
it says that there are other speakers on
the chat it's saying
loudly the speakers please
yeah um can someone advise me who the
other speakers are
i'll i'll mute now and if you can just
get the other speakers in please first
and then i'll make i'll open the debate
thank you
we do have the um the application agent
and local residents also down to speak
all right um
speaker against it mr mr madden do you
have mr madden
yes can you hear me okay yeah mr madden
apologies for that
i was getting a bit worried then yeah
don't worry you're fine uh you have
three minutes mr madden thank you
thank you very much on behalf of local
residents i'd like to thank trafford
planning for taking the middle ground on
this case by taking into consideration
the request to remove the existing
condition
and also the impact on the local
community as residents
we agree that the condition to keep the
use of this premise is limited to a bank
is no longer viable
and that a new use should be found
however local residents are completely
against any proposal for the removal of
the existing conditions without any new
conditions being included
we're encouraged to see the new
conditions proposed by the planning
officer
which addressed most of the concerns of
local residents should the existing
condition be removed for the following
reasons
the opening hours and the delivery hours
we agree with the new i was proposed the
residents of both flat 1a which is above
and number one both agree that it's
reasonable for the opening hours to be
extended to 8am until 8pm
as the previous open hours of the bank
were from around 10am till 4pm
this will bring the premises in line
with the other units in the parade and
protect them from
more noise disturbances of sociable
hours of whatever the future of the
premises is
and the resident at number one has also
asked me to ask that if these hours were
kind of set in stone would he get the um
would he get the chance to comment uh
should there and be any new applications
to extend the hours
and that should venom can answer that at
the end and the service plan
the requirement for a service plan helps
address many of the major concerns of
local residents the main concern has and
always
will be the movement the loading
unloading and parking of vehicles in
this location
evidence of this is the implementation
of a parking scheme that is due to start
this coming tuesday which will make
hawthorne avenue and connecting roads
residents only from
10 am to 3 pm in addition the
introduction of a plan for waste storage
and limited collection hours should
reduce disturbances and on sociable
hours for nearby residents
by following the traffic business waste
duty of care policy
keep the area outside the premises clean
and tidy with the waste stored safely
and securely
the boundary wall the return of the
boundary wall around flat 1a is most
welcomed by all residents
it restores a level of privacy for
residents of 1a
who have been left upset following the
removal of an old hedge-rolling wall
with little to no notice and also brings
back the form of visual segregation
between the creative shops and half on
avenue that had previously been in place
for over 30 years
the travel plan is a great is a great
incentive for this particular location
giving the limited parking spaces
available to the rear of the property
that may be used as customer parking
if the waste plan includes multiple pins
for recycling
and therefore and they're made to be
safely secured
there's a possibility of losing one or
even two of the spaces to the rear of
the property
and so to conclude the residents of
hawthorne avenue and collective roads
are fully aware that they live by
prairie shops and take no pleasure in
seeing this particular address vacant
and in the condition it economy finds
itself
we applaud trafford for being fair in
this process by proposing a fair and
sensible solution
and feel that if all the proposed
conditions are applied and enforced with
the sensible and safe plans before the
reopening of the premises
there should be little reason for
complaints from local residents going
forwards
thank you very much thank you mr madden
um we have mr sutton speaking in favor
of the application mr sutton are you
there
yes i am yeah mr sutton you have
three minutes to put across your views
thank you
thank you chair the application site has
been vacant since may 2018 despite
ongoing marketing
the condition restricting the use of the
site as a bank does not meet the
required tests of being either
reasonable
or necessary this is agreed with
officers
the application site lies within a local
shopping centre
which adopted planning policy confirms
will be a focus for convenience
retail floor space to meet local needs
the
existing parade has two current
long-standing vacancies
which in addition to the application
site gives it a vacancy rate
of 33 which is the highest in the ward
since the submission of the application
the applicant now has an offer from a
national convenience store operator to
occupy the site
as you've heard a recent premises
license has been granted which allows
opening from 6 am
to 11 pm
the suggested restriction on opening
hours prohibits though
the proposed occupation of the unit
simply the proposed occupier
will not take the unit based on the
current hours proposed
we understand the concerns about the use
of the site being used as a gym or a day
nursery
the applicant would suggest that rather
there should simply be a condition which
prohibits
such uses on the site coupled with the
revision of condition one to the wording
to allow opening from either six or
seven in the morning through till 10 or
11
at night it should be noted that the
existing convenience store in the parade
has is entitled to open until 11 p.m at
night
we have also provided your officers with
examples of 11 other shops in the
immediate area
which are open from early in the morning
through till either 10 10 30
or 11 p.m at night which includes the go
local at ridings road in timperley the
spa
on park road in timperley the nissan
park road in templeley
what we are proposing is not
unreasonable
simply if you cannot locate a local
needs convenience store in a designated
local shopping center
where can you place it we have heard
from the member the concerns about
deliveries
the proposed occupation by convenience
store will only require about three
deliveries a week i would suggest that
that number is
far outweighed by the level of home
deliveries and amazon deliveries
which occurred to residents on hawthorne
avenue
i am pleased from the comments from the
local resident i think we can
that they are broadly happy um with the
proposals subject to these conditions
the point about the boundary wall uh the
land outside number one a
is not is owned by the applicant it's
not within the demise of the
uh owners of the the residents of number
1a
in summary the application is consistent
with the council's planning policy
guidance and simply seeks to remove an
unlawful condition to bring a
long-standing vacant site back into
beneficial use
in summary the importance of local
e-shopping is well established during
the covet crisis
and this application will help
invigorate an existing shopping create
and create jobs
there is much to commend this
application and we respectfully request
that the application be granted in
accordance with the recommendation of
officers
albeit with our suggested changes to the
conditions
which are necessary to ensure occupation
thank you
thank you mr sutton um council of
ministers like to comment first
counselor minis
hi uh thank you chair so um i have i
have one
um fairly large concern and that is it's
around actually
um times of uh deliveries because this
is what's going to make the difference
between
large difference between um
what was the use of the building to what
uh
will be the use of building and um to
have deliveries allowing between
being allowed from eight a.m to eight pm
i don't know how many of you go along
park road i
i cycle along it um most days and i can
tell you now that it's
it's you know backed up at rush hour
and there is a primary school saint
hughes that's not far away
and that junction of where where
hawthorne is is extreme it's
like a you know because you have a the
hill going up to the tram stop
there's a blind part going over the top
um i'll tell you the the what what
there's a grave danger and i've actually
seen myself i've witnessed
is when i came off the tram one day
coming back from work
a child was knocked off his bike and i i
stayed with the child until
the paramedics and and the mother the
child arrived
so um and that was due to the
um traffic on park road building up
uh child coming out and and uh a
motorbike knocking
the child off so this is something that
um
i i'm not willing to budge on i'm afraid
um
especially the the parking of um
of the delivery lorry so i would like
restrictions
um not not rush hour basically
so i'd like times where um if we are
going to
if it's going to get approved i would
like conditions about delivery times
um to definitely avoid the rush hour
times
so um because highways should be a
concern
for for is it is a planning reason to
reject
um and unless that's changed i will be
voting against the application i'm
afraid however much
uh people are happy with other parts of
it now um and i'm really really glad
they brought the wall back and i've put
out with lots of things
i'm afraid that the safety is paramount
um to all residents of simply including
myself
thank you
sorry about that everybody um yeah thank
you council minister councillor dr
barkley you're to go next
thank you chairman uh unlike uh council
administrators i also have uh really
grave concerns about
extra cars and and the problem with
traffic
it is absolutely terrible road it's
incredibly busy it's bumper to bumper
at the beginnings ends of days and
beginnings and ends of weekend days it's
incredibly hard
to go along there and the side shoots
and the roads
are obviously where the bank was
situated parking along there is also
incredibly tight it's and it's used by
when
in pre-covered football traffic uh
people going to work on the metro link
it's really really hazardous so
therefore i'm really concerned because
the bank hasn't been in use for a couple
of years
and so obviously that situation has been
that no one has really been parking to
go into into the property
so suddenly we're going to be bringing
it back to life which is obviously
reasonable we want to do that but i just
do have great concerns about the traffic
and particularly had it as a site or as
a as a kind of commercial use that
brought a lot of visitors
to that particular area i would i do
have concerns and i would be really
grateful we could just
ask again our highways officer if you
could just explain why we shouldn't be
concerned about that thank you chairman
i'm cu councillor dr barkley um mr
evanson
would you like to comment on what
council dr barclays just said
yep certainly um yeah in terms of um
the proposal which is before us this
evening um
with regards to the application itself
in the removal of of the restrictions on
the condition too
we we whilst we we do share a number of
those concerns and we were made aware of
of the concerns of the local residents
well before the application came in
we found it we we found ourselves in an
extremely difficult position
in that the application was for the
change of use
but which has been explained already by
my colleagues and the planning
authority and therefore
we found ourselves with our hands tied
behind a back to a large degree
in that it's it's a local
shopping area for which he's in in the
policy
and the application which is before us
this evening
it was purely to change the condition
the use
and all to the condition so it
it wasn't a convenience store as what
has been
elaborated and what's come to to
fruition
this evening and by local residents of
their their expectation
so we found it extremely difficult to
provide
an objection to the application but i
don't dispute that there are concerns of
the local residents and
and i do share those but
what we did recommend was was the issue
of the servicing
for which there is a condition around
that um
and that's how that's all we felt we
could
um secure on the back of the the
application or the nature of the
application
so unfortunately yeah we do share those
concerns
but putting everything in and the
balance and the nature of the
application
found it extremely difficult to be able
to sustain an objection
okay thank you mr evanson um
okay thanks for that counselor williams
you'd like to comment
thank you chair um i'm gonna try and be
brief now because i'm conscious of time
it strikes me that it's really welcomed
the
people who were originally objecting to
the application have
referenced in their representations that
they no longer hold um
those objections so on that basis i'm
happy to move
that we uh that we approved this
application tonight
um i'm i'm not agreeing with the
representation we've received from
the applicant the condition one be
amended i think if other members feel
differently they can may
move to that effect i am just wondering
though with perhaps
uh and one i'm not sure which officer
but if an officer could
reflect on condition two and the
contributions of council and municipal
councillor dr barclay
i'm wondering if it's remotely um
practical or feasible for us to amend
the hours
um 8 am till 8 pm
in light of the fact that that could
allow delivery within um
the shower traffic because what we've
heard is kavats i know what park votes
like it gets
heavily congested and so i'm just
wondering if that's remotely feasible
or not if somebody could comment on that
thank you chad
can we can we get an answer to that
question
yes yeah it is it would be um we could
look at
um the condition three that talks about
the moment servicing and deliveries
and at the moment we're focusing on um
and location that will take place within
the area so we want a defined area for
for services and deliveries
we could almost um amalgamate that
condition with condition three
say details of you know the time of
everything
to be agreed we're not specifying
an open range but further details to be
submitted
and that would also be that once the
applicant has their end user
they'll be able to give us more specific
um time scales
and we would of course um we could amend
the reason
to make note um the highways issue
and be mindful of that when we would be
reviewing any further information
okay so we'd agree to remove the
condition
that the premises have got to be a bank
but we'd leave the
opening hours if you like delegated to
officers to come up with a
an agreeable solution
um as detailed in the office report is
regarding the hours of services and
deliveries yeah
there's a new condition what i'm
suggesting is rather than
specify an open range of hours
we asked for more of a servicing
delivery strategy as part of condition
three that would allow um officers
and the agent to agree hours um
upon the the with the end user but being
mindful of the comments
from councilmanist and councillor but
sparkly on the rush hour
thank you thank you for that miss milner
um satisfies me
i mean if any of the members feel
differently that they can move to that
effect but thank you ms milner and i
trust that officers can just
um execute that without any further
instruction
thank you for that council williams
councillor morgan you'd like to come in
thank you chair um yeah um i'm gonna
very much echo councillor williams that
i'm happy to
second um his his uh proposal to accept
officer recommendations and with with
that amendment that we've just discussed
um i i honestly see very little really
reason to object to this
um and if we if again if we don't
if we can't prove this tonight as a as a
as a commercial development
railroad shops i really do think it's
it's very difficult i think officers
have come up with a very
fair um proposal um and
i i really do thank mrs milner for that
suggestion and um
yeah i i i i i'm too honest with you i i
would be nice
as somebody who lives not far from from
there here um it'd be nice to see these
shops
this this building occupied rather than
as it's been for two and a half years
um unoccupied and i really do look at
some of the objections and
i've gone through quite a few of them
and um i i think some of
doomsday scenarios and i don't i don't
just don't agree with them on on some of
them
um and um those shops have been there a
very long time probably longer than i've
been
been around um and i think we we
definitely need to
to look at this as a positive
development so um i'm gonna i will
second uh councillor williams um
um chair thank you thank you councillor
morgan councillor hartley
all right thank you chair i think um
what i was going to say has been
adequately covered by by other members
who spoke so
uh uh yeah i agree with the uh with
emotions subject to those medical
conditions and
uh nothing further to us thanks chad
thank you councillor hartley councillor
minister did you want to come back in
thank you chair um yes i've if if
if we can have um obviously not at rush
hour and we can make
deliveries at safe times um i'd like
the ti the times of opening i i don't
agree with the applicant that they want
to
extend it i i think that the officers
have got that part right
and but i think that the deliveries the
servicing as we call it and deliveries
of lorries and etc anita and any
deliveries really need
to be not rush hour because it just
contributes to
the already existing problem because
barclays didn't have that you see that
there is a difference there
between a barclays and a shop that the
barclays didn't have
the same um level of of those but if we
can do that then that would be
and then in which in which case then i
could
but that's not here is it that's not
that's not here at the moment is it so
we will be approving what's written here
on paper which is 8 am to 8 pm that's my
problem
yes we're trying to edge you over the
line council a minute we can't yes
the paper still says have we can we have
a change now can we have a change of
time now
miss milner what i'd suggest to
calculate is that we
work with the agent and with our
colleagues within the highways
department
who review the um hours of
delivery and services as part of a
reconfigured condition three so the
the paper as you refer to in front of
you the condition two
which sets out thousands eighth place we
remove that and we say that this details
are to be
agreed so that we then allow for further
conversation
on that being mindful of the comments
that you've been made
and made and the comments from our
highways officer
council the minis you want to come back
just something so if
so now are we then voting on it with
without the 8 a.m to 8 p.m and that's
yet to be determined is that what the
amended version that we're going to now
vote on is
yes i'm suggesting that you we remove
conviction 2
and that we um we um amend condition
3 so the um another
servicing strategy is submitted with
hours of deliveries
and servicing to be agreed okay but then
we'll well we can vote
then that that i can i can vote on let's
just do with that i would
without that i'd it'd be a no-no for me
thanks
okay okay i think we'll go to the vote
it's been second
being proposed and seconded by council
williams and councilman morgan or rather
yeah council morgan that we grant this
application subject to further
discussions in the way
man and ms milner is described around
those delivery times
um council williams are you voting for
or against the application
uh vote to approve the application with
the amendment summarized by
ms milner thank you thank you councillor
stenit are you voting for or against the
application
for the application cheer thank you
councillor morgan are you voting for or
against the application or the
application chair
thank you councillor minis are you
voting for or against the application
you're on mute uh councilor minis
put to apologize so uh we understand so
my understanding is the opening hours
are 8 a.m to 8 p.m
but and no wriggle room for that
whatsoever and that the delivery times
are yet to be determined but it will
be shorter than the 8 a.m to 8 p.m and
we are going to consider
rush hour traffic under which terms that
those terms i would say yes
for but if those terms are not there
then it would be a no
with respect councilman i think that's
what we've been saying for the last 10
minutes that's okay that's okay
then i'm just going to i'm just making
it clear that's all thank you
thank you we know where exactly where
you coming from every one of us thank
you very much thank you you're voting in
favor i'll take that councillor
stanley how you vote in favor of the
application or again over with ms
milner's amendments
thank you councillor procter how would
you like to vote
well the application to grant thank you
councillor hartley how would you like to
vote
thank you chair for the application to
grant with the amended conditions thank
you
councillor rigby how would you like to
vote thank you i'm for the application
thank you councillor jerome how would
you like to vote
the application was the amendments thank
you thank you
councillor dr barclay how would you like
to vote i i
i i'm in favor of the amended proposal
thank you and i'll be voting in favor so
again that is unanimous that's 11 votes
we've got there everybody
that application has been granted
subject to the
conditions miss milner outlined earlier
and there will be further discussions on
those delivery times
thank you everybody um we're going to go
to the next item
and that is the gender item six that's
chesham house on 101 church road in
ermeston
and i think miss kohler is going to give
us an introduction to this item
i am thank you chad i'll just share my
screen with you just sticking just bear
with me
thank you is everybody seeing that yes
thank you good um
to start off with just an explanation
about uh
what this report does and what article
or direction
um it is because it's been sometimes
it's brought an article
direction to the community and there are
a number of new members
across this in a in a committee
situation before
um so an article four direction enables
a local planning authority to remove
committee development rights for certain
classes of development
um trafford already has a borough wide
article for direction which removes
permitted development rights for small
houses in multiple occupation and
there's a number of conservation areas
in the borough
where household and permitted
development rights are also removed
through this
through this route in this particular
case
um we're seeking to remove british
development rights for the demolition
of an individual property chesham house
uh 101 church road in erneston
it's considered to be necessary because
as the demolition cheshire house
uh would be in our view prejudicial to
the proper planning of the area
and constitute a threat to the amenities
of the area and that is the statutory
test
are set out in the legislation um there
are two
ways of bringing forward an article for
an immediate one
or none immediate in this case an
immediate article for direction
is required as the property could be
demolished in the 12 months between a
non-immediate
article for direction being made and
then coming into
so with a non-immediate one you have
that 12-month period
where it is not actually in effect but
has been made an immediate one comes
into effect immediately
it is made um i'll show you
the property if you can see that there's
there's the location the property on
church road in ernst you can see it's in
a group of uh
similar scaled and similar ages as well
um and there's a couple of photos
go to there go to there i'll just leave
leave that one up for now
um the cheshire house is not protected
by any statutory heritage
designation it's not a listed building
it's not in a conservation area but it
is considered to be a non-designated
heritage asset its demolition would be
harmful in office's view to the visual
immunities of the area it is attractive
in its own right
an important part also of a wider group
and would lead to the total loss of of
its heritage significance if it were to
be demolished
um conversation may be payable if a
future planning application for
demolition is refused
and members will know what already had
um two applications for for demolition
and replacement with with semi-detached
properties
and we do have also had an application
for prior approval
demolition under development um
right which is is um still has a couple
of things to to run on it
so there is there is a there is a threat
we are aware this is not
we're not taking this action without any
uh understanding that
there's any intention to demolish
but but any conversation payable would
not be payable on the making or
confirming of the article for direction
it would not be a matter to immediately
consider
particularly to consider with the merits
of the article for direction but it's
but it would be um uh considered at the
time of a future planning application so
future planning application came in
and was refused um then the
those with an interest in the land could
seek compensation for
um the cost involved in abortive work or
loss from that removal of development
rights
officers are therefore proposing and
this is part of the recommendation
for you this evening that any future
planning application
which may generate a subsequent
compensation claim would be referred to
the committee for determination
and then committee can weigh that
potential and the size of any claim in
the planning balance
on that application um it's also
important to note that no consultation
has been carried out at this stage
that consultation and notification to
those with an interest in
the land which include the owner of the
property and the applicant for planning
permission
and also with surrounding residents and
other interested parties
would be carried out once the direction
is made before it is confirmed
this direction would need to be
confirmed after a six month period
um we wouldn't see this would be no
requirement to consult beforehand the
processes make
consult um it's like a tree preservation
order um
in that sense um and so approval sorts
for members to make the direction
therefore move on
the next part of the process um it is
noted however that previous applications
for planning
for demolition of the property have
actually generated a relatively high
level
of opposition they haven't been before
the committee because we have been
refuting those applications
um in accordance with the with
representations that we have received so
they haven't triggered a referral to
committee
but representations are specifically
objective principle to the demolition of
the building
on the basis of harm to the immunities
of the area which would arise
it's therefore likely there would be
some local support for the article for
direction
um ms kerbin the council's planning
solicitor
will now explain the legal process to
make the direction
thank you chairman
thank you very much um
so yeah the um the recommendation is to
make
an article for direction with immediate
effect um as you've been
been advised um that process
um that would be followed um
should the should the uh recommendation
be approved
is that firstly the direction would be
made um
and that direction will take immediate
effect once it's been served on
um on the owner um
so following making of the direction the
notices are served
um they'll be served on the owner as
well as being posted on site
advertised in the press and the
secretary of state is also notified
and that notice would give 21 days for
interested parties to make any
representations
um that's the minimum requirement it can
be it can be longer
and the representations would then be
received and
considered and in accordance with the
recommendation
if that were approved um if no
objections were received
or only positive representations were
received
the recommendation would allow for um
for legal services to confirm um the
direction
if not um and objections were received
then the decision to confirm would come
back to committee
um and then once confirmed
um or if confirmed i should say the
notice would be given
um in the same way that it had been
previously
um once once the direction was
um was confirmed and so
once the note once the um direction has
taken effect
um as as was said earlier
it will um remove those permitted
development rights to demolish and the
owner would then be free to make an
application
and for them would have to make an
application for demolition
if that was what they wanted to do thank
you
thank you miss colburn um any members
wishing to speak
to this item counselor dr barclay
um thank you chairman i i totally
support the uh making of an article for
direction
i mean the property is absolutely
stunning and obviously it's
it's so beautifully and it's i mean the
whole street is
just so so attractive we shouldn't do
anything to happen to remove that
property at all i think it is
really really important if there is a
possibility being demolished that we do
prevent that because
it is it is stunning and it's very
historic in a kind of historic sense
it's not ultra historic it's a very
beautiful building and has
kind of links to the past and i think it
would be absolutely tragic to lose this
and i totally
i totally support the the making of the
article for thank you
thank you councillor dr barclay
councillor win stanley
uh thank you chair i'd like to propose
that we accept the
um i know church road
if those buildings are fabulous um
and to remove one of them will be
criminal and i've also
i actually live in ireland and i've seen
a couple of buildings which have been
demolished and i am
horrified they were allowed to be
demolished so absolutely
in favor of the um of the immediate
article for direction
thank you jen thank you councillor and
stanley apologies for missing you
earlier
um councillor proctor uh thank you chair
yes i wholeheartedly agree with this i
mean in my ward i've actually
in the past i've been in similar houses
to this and uh
you know quite stunning buildings i
appreciate it's not a listed building
but
they are quite remarkable and i think if
uh if it was demolished and replaced by
simply properties that stick out like a
sore thumb
so i think this is a really positive
thing to do
and i think if if we didn't do this i
think it would have potentially a
detrimental effect on immunity so i
think i'm
highly supportive of it and uh
i hope it's uh it's approved thank you
chair
and counselor proctor councillor morgan
thank you chair i'm going to repeat
everybody and say i absolutely agree
with this um
and support the officer recommendations
um we
i wish we did this more and as as
council proctor's just certainly
councilman stanley
i've seen too many beautiful buildings
be torn down and it's
it's tragedy um and i do wish there was
something
more we could do in terms of national
legislation to protect um properties
like this so yeah absolutely
wholeheartedly support it
thank you council of minis you'd like to
comment
um yes thank you i i completely support
this
and it's actually i've got a question
about another building that i
fear um someone will try to demolish as
well
and that i'd like to but i'd like to
know how
one gets an article for and possibly
like you know
to go further and and just say outright
you can't demolish a building i'd like
to know further details on that if um
if some who who is the correct person
that can
tell me how to how to prevent that
happening to building in the future
because i there's one that i think will
that will end up happening to
in simply um yeah i i don't think it's
appropriate to deal with that yeah
but i'd like to separately then i'll
come back and ask you so if you
if you if you drop me an email um
either i or the appropriate officer will
will respond to that that's great thank
you rebecca thank you
okay we'll go to a vote it's been moved
and seconded that we
approved this article for um at 101
church road
um councillor williams how would you
like to vote
to grant the article for directive thank
you thank you
councillor stenit how would you like to
vote
thank you councillor morgan how would
you like to vote
support officer recommendations to grant
the article for chair
thank you councillor minis how would you
like to vote yes supporter officer
recommendation please uh to grant
article 4 thank you thank you councillor
stanley how would you like to vote
to grant the article for um
direction thank you councillor procter
how would you like to vote
for officer recommendation to grant
thank you jeff thank you councillor
hartley how would you like to vote
thank you chair in favor of the
recommendation to make the direction
thank you
thank you councillor rigby how would you
like to vote
thank you councillor jerome how would
you like to vote
i'm also in favor of officer
recommendation thank you
council dr barclay how would you like to
vote support the
article thank you and i'll be supporting
article four so again that's unanimous
that's 11 votes in favor that article 4
has been granted if that's the right way
of putting it at 101
church road and that concludes
the agendas on the items on the agenda
and i don't know if there's any other
business we need to discuss uh rebecca
not from me thank you chairman no